c'est l'heure à présent de votre page
était ce soir nous nous rendons à
aubigny sur nère dans le cher la ville
accueille jusqu'à ce soir ces fameuses
fêtes franco-écossaise un moment
important pour la vie qui renoue chaque
année avec son passé écossais on
retrouve sur place bérénice tu vas y
bonsoir bérénice expliquez-nous un peu
le genre et entre aubigny sur nère et
l'ecosse et bien on aubigny petite ville
du cher savez-vous était écossaise
pendant des centaines d'années alors
vous allez me dire une histoire
étonnante une histoire incroyable mais
c'est vrai sur fond de guerre de cent
ans
alors ici les fêtes franco écossais
c'est un véritable succès vous
n'imaginez pas la foule ici venus
écouter forcément les cornemuses mais
surtout admirer les hommes en kilt
regardez c'est une histoire
extraordinaire qui lie aubigny sur nère
à la ville écossaise des dictons on est
en pleine guerre de cent ans en 1415 la
bataille d'azincourt plus de soldats
français terminait le charles ciss le
roi fou donne la france à son gendre le
roi d'angleterre
et puis il ya son fils à charles ciss
que le futur charles vii va dans les
jupons de son oncle le duc de berry à
bourges et de il deviendra le terrain le
le petit roi de bourges et est donc à
partir de là elle fera appel aux
écossais et pour remercier de l'avoir
aidé à mettre un terme à la guerre de
cent ans
le roi charles vii a offert la ville de
beni agence quartz le prestigieux chef
de l'armée écossaise nous sommes alors
en 1423 quelques années plus tard et
depuis 50 ans aubigny fait de cette
histoire
habillée en kilt de la tête aux pieds
ils viennent de toute la france et ils
sont divisé en clans
j'ai trouvé des amis des pères le clan
un bon esprit et une seconde famille
voilà c'est quoi les valeurs du clan
cameron les valeurs du clan cabrol comme
tout comme tous les clans c'est
l'honnêteté la fidélité et la
camaraderie le partage d'autres ne font
partie d'aucune chapelle
seulement là pour l'ambiance et le
folklore les doigts jean-pierre je
vouvoyais cherchez plus ou moins dans le
stand ça vous tenterait un kit comment
que ça me tente un kit
c'est marrant ces banques moi je fais
des jeunes amis je fais partie d'un
conte traditionnel c'est la musique de
soleil du berry que je fais mais en
revanche inquiète pas pour m'amuser pour
ma collection c'est rigolo mais là j'ai
vu avec des piles pour enfants il ya pas
ma taille parce que moi je suis balèze
et du foie gras sous un soleil de plomb
devant un public de plus en plus
nombreux chaque année
les écossais et les autres ont défilé
dans les rues dominique les cecos et
vous les trouvez comment
mais magnifique beau c'est difficile
c'est que du bonheur ça vous fait
plaisir de les voir car là ça me fait
juste les coups des coups qui me répond
et ses gonds le bonheur est là il est où
le bonheur il est là aujourd'hui madame
en trois jours aubigny petite ville de
6000 habitants aura drainé plus de 30000
personnes entre tradition et folklore le
fait franco écossaises ont décidé
toujours le plat bonsoir dionne
macmillan bon choix bernis merlin vous
êtes le provoost du district 10 lauriane
oui en écosse à cuincy peu au maire de
chez nous oui comment vous expliquer un
tel succès ici de ces fêtes franco
écossaise qu'est ce que les gens
viennent chercher je crois qui vient
chercher d'abord la musique mais surtout
il y a une odeur alliance entre la
france et les cosses qu'on peut lire là
bas mais c'est l'esprit de amitié le
friendship on dit en écosse l'amitié
entre les deux pays et qui vient ici on
reconnaît ce qui vient ici il trouve
l'amitié il trouve la musique beaucoup à
boire beaucoup on avait d'abord aux
jeunes élèves nous on a bu louis c'est
sa région sont très très chaud dites moi
c'est une tradition ça reflète ses
traditions et les gens viennent chercher
ça aussi ah oui pourquoi c'est important
de perpétuer cette tradition pour les
jeunes surtout qu'ils comprennent
l'histoire de l'ecosse l'histoire de la
musique traditionnelle jouée par les
cornemuses et les tambours le
l'instrument s'est depuis longtemps
l'instrument decosse c'est un instrument
certes cette sympathique vous avez le
gronde exposition à lorient la fête de
musique celte
mais ici à aubigny scène se réjouissent
et jouer ensemble les français les échos
c'est est ce que justement en écosse la
cornemuse elle a autant de succès ce
qu'à l'école par exemple les enfants
apprennent l'instrument est ce que et
inès un peu avec alors ice notait-on 1
nous avons presque une douzaine de pipe
band avec beaucoup de jeunes avec des
vieillards d'aussi qui joue même 70 79
ans avec une oie addington paddington à
l'année 2009 était le le rail band de
l'année en écosse et on trouve au lycée
aux écoles séquence primaire que les
jeunes qui vient apprendre le corno muse
et les tambours et puis niveau joindre
un appel band joue il comme muse avec on
le voit effectivement que c'est une
vraie tradition chez vous c'est encore
très important ce soir jeudi juste au
téléspectateur il n'est pas trop tard
vous pouvez encore venir ici parce qu'il
ya la retraite aux flambeaux et puis le
feu d'artifice oui et c'est magnifique
ici à aubigny c'est pour nous les
écossais un accueil très chaleureux
madame le maire merci mr et nice